I slept at the gym cuz I didn't have
enough money to pay two rents I went to
California without knowing anybody and I
found this guy online who had a good gym
so I just asked him if I could just work
for free he ended up paying me minimum
wage but he got on his gym floor on a
stool and was like anybody want to give
this guy a place to live cuz I had just
driven there without any plan and one
guy came up to me looked me up and down
he's like you can stay at my place I got
a bedroom for you we actually are still
friends to this day and he was like hey
just get me to stop eating and drinking
so much on the weekends and we'll call
it a fair deal and so I was meal
prepping anyways and so he would just
like spend Sundays meal prepping with me
so that's was kind of part of the
exchange so so I went from 300 bucks a
month renting a bedroom in Chino uh
California to moving out to Huntington
Beach and my rent at my gym was 5,000 a
month I mean I think I was making maybe
$4,000 a month online by having just I
had like 20 guys who were paying me 200
bucks a month to like give them Fitness
and Nutrition stuff but when I had my
gym that was still less than my rent I
was like well I mean there's a roof here
and there's a you know I can buy a
blanket and put a pillow on the turf and
follow a day and that's pretty much what
I did